Jason, Shawn,
congratulations, you've
made it to the final
round of this competition.
When you guys showed
up to the forge,
we asked you to forge our judge
Ben Abbott's favorite knife,
the Celtic ring knife.
Now, we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history,
from the same kilted region.
That weapon is-- the
Irish ring-hilted sword.
[exhales]
WIL WILLIS: Dating back
to the 12th century,
the Irish ring hilted sword
was a classic European weapon,
with a blade reaching
lengths of up to 40 inches.
The broad, double-edged weapon
featured a distinctive ring
pommel that was key for
counterbalancing its weight,
allowing for swift
and deadly cuts.
Commonly used by the
elite mercenaries known
as Gallowglass, the
well-balanced sword
complemented their
superior fighting
techniques that were
revered throughout Ireland
in the Middle Ages.
Although warriors such as the
Gallowglass no longer exist,
the weapon's symbolism is still
represented in popular culture
today and can be seen
on the television
show "Game of
Thrones," where one
of the most feared
characters, The Mountain,
wields his ring hilted sword.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck.
Good luck man.
[rock music]
SHAWN SHROPSHIRE: My
name is Shawn Shropshire,
from Piedmont, Oklahoma.
I'm pretty confident
that I can win this.
I've got a one-in-four shot
before we swing a hammer.
If I were to win the
money, my son has already
said we're going on vacation.
I would prefer to use
it for some shop tools,
so maybe we can strike a
balance between the two.
[music playing]
OK, try to thin this
out and draw it out now.
I'm going in for my
first heat on the steel.
I go to the power hammer.
Within about four or five
strikes, it stops on me.
If I don't get the
power hammer fixed,
the entire schedule that
I've had in my head for this
is out the window.
Back in business.
It's not perfect.
There's a few things I
still need to tweak on it.
But I need to
start moving steel.
I've never made fullers
this length before.
If I grind through all
the way, then it's trash.
I need the quench to go right.
Because if I have
to start over now,
it's going to put me way behind.
To catch back up to
this point and still
be able to get the
handle on the way I want,
I'd be pushing it to finish.
So I really need
things to go right.
I've got a little bit
of a wiggle in it.
The steel's hard.
I've got a little
bit of a warp in it.
But I've got enough steel
left that I've still
got to grind away
that I don't think
that's going to be an issue.
Should be as easy
as eating pancakes.
I'm going to use some liquid
steel to assemble the guard.
And then it's just a matter
of getting everything
fitted up before it hardens.
I've got the sword together.
It looks like a
battle-worthy weapon.
[rock music]
JASON BROWN: My
name is Jason Brown.
And I live in Brevard,
North Carolina.
My daughters and my wife say,
man, you need to smile more.
I don't know why I don't smile.
My mom and dad spent a
fortune on my braces,
but I will smile if I
win "Forged in Fire."
Steel's moving really good.
I got a lot of work to do.
But so far, I feel really good.
I have an issue with my sword.
It's a little thin
up by the tang.
I want to put a few beads of
weld on it to strengthen it.
[bleep]
This made my blade
worse than I started.
Mind's sort of
flustered right now.
And it kind of melted the edge.
I'm going to do a stack weld
and build it up that way.
My welding finally worked.
I'm going to stop the weld
now and start grinding.
Right now, I'm engraving
Celtic runes on here.
This one means family,
or relationships,
because I've made a bunch of
new "Forged in Fire" family.
I look forward to going back and
seeing how my blade tests out.
And I'm glad it's
over right now.
Can finally get
some sleep, maybe.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the kill test.
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your Irish ring hilted swords
can do, I will take your weapon
and deliver killing blows
on this feral boar carcass.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
I am.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
All right, Jason.
First up, when I grab
on to it, it feels
good in the hands-- a good fit.
Now, swinging this is sweet.
You have a very sharp
edge that cuts easily
into this wild boar carcass.
It will kill.
Good job, Jason.
Thank you.
All right, Shawn, you ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[rock music]
Ooh.
All right, Shawn, let's talk
about your weapon right here.
First up, when I grabbed
on to the handle,
it's got a good feel to that.
I like that you put
some grooves in there,
because it fits nicely to
where my hand locks into it.
And I get a very secure fit.
A little heavier, but the
weight helps push and cut
into this wild boar carcass.
And most of all, it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
Good job.
Ben?
[suspenseful music]
BEN ABBOTT: Welcome
to the strength test--
the dreaded ice chop.
To test the strength and
durability of your swords,
as well as their
overall construction,
I'm going to be chopping
mercilessly into
this unforgiving block of ice.
Remember, this test
is all about what
that ice does to your
ring hilted swords,
and not what your
swords do to the ice.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
Yeah, go ahead.
Good.
[rock music]
Well, Jason, first
things first, the warp--
I think that it being off center
made it rotate in my hand.
But the balance on this sword,
as you can see, is beautiful.
It's comfortable to wield.
And your sword held up.
Well done.
Thank you.
Shawn, you're up.
How you feeling?
Nervous, but excited.
All right, let's do it.
[rock music]
(WHISPERS) Nice.
Well, Shawn, the weight on
this is a little tip-heavy.
I would have liked a little
bit more counterbalance on it.
But that being said, it's
still a lot of fun to swing.
Your edge held up beautifully.
Everything's right and tight.
Well done.
Thank you, sir.
Next up is the sharpness test.
And for that, I
give you to Dave.
[suspenseful music]
OK, gentlemen, now, to test
the sharpness of your blade,
I'll be cutting through
this sugar cane.
I'll use both edges
of your blade.
Now, unlike the strength
test, this is all about what
your blades do to that target.
We want to see those
cuts nice and clean,
not canes broken or
pushed out of the way.
Jason, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I am.
OK.
[rock music]
All right, Jason, your handle
construction, you can see
how square that is right there.
When that was in
my backhand cut,
I actually got into those
canes, and then it rolled.
Your tang is now kind of
kicking off to one side.
So that probably happened
as that blade caught
that last cane and yanked down.
But definitely a sharp
blade, really nice.
Shawn, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
OK.
[rock music]
Nice.
OK.
First up, your handle
construction I like a lot.
It's not rotating in my hand.
It's a heavier sword,
but the cuts are clean.
It's definitely a sharp blade.
I like that.
Well done.
Thank you.
Jason, Shawn, the judges'
deliberation is complete.
They've made their
final decision.
The next "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
Shawn.
Congratulations, you're the
new "Forged in Fire" champion.
Jason, unfortunately, your
blade didn't make the cut.
Please surrender your blade.
I would have
liked to have won.
But I'm proud of what
I've done, I mean,
throughout this whole
series of tests.
I made a strong, sharp blade.
And it performed equally
as well, so I mean, I'm--
I'm happy with it.
Shawn, congratulations.
You're the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
How do you feel about that?
It doesn't suck.
[laughter]
No, it does not.
Shawn, please present
your blade to the judges.
SHAWN SHROPSHIRE:
This whole experience,
it's pushed me physically.
It's pushed me mentally.
Parts of it have
been pretty brutal.
Thank you, guys.
And I wouldn't trade a
minute of it for anything.
I've-- I've had the
time of my life.
[theme music]